the last suit he has isn't even designed
for him to be able to survive using it
the first suit is all about will this
get me and my ego and my precious
physical frame out of this cave I'm in
and into the desert where maybe the
cavalry can come get me and bring me
back to my stupid life right right right
the last one is not designed to be able
to do its job and have you make it past
it so that's the great you know Joseph
Campbell mythology of like ultimately
you go from refusing the call of being a
serendipitous hero and by the end you're
willing to give the ultimate sacrifice
your life despite your family and your
groundedness and your desire to not want
to do that so that that community can
thrive we all love ironman 3000 and we
are all super sad that he is gone
however he went out in the best possible
way saving the whole entire universe and
now as you just saw we have an even
bigger reason to love him and an even
bigger reason to be more sad that he's
gone how's it going everybody it's
Warren and as you just saw Iron Man's
last suit was meant literally to save
the universe the mark 85 ayran man suit
was designed for a very specific purpose
and I'll break it all down in this video
quick reminder if you'd like a chance to
win an Iron Man helmet a Captain America
shield and Infinity Gauntlet or another
Marvel Legends item be sure to subscribe
to my channel I'm doing a giveaway at
four hundred and fifty thousand
subscribers I'll be picking three
winners so Robert Downey jr. said that
the last suit that Iron Man used was not
designed for him to be able to survive
using it and when he says survive using
it he's not talking about using it as
armor to fight he's talking about using
his armor to perform the snap he said
that the last suit is not designed to do
its job and him make it past it and it's
very clear what the job is the job is to
collect the stones and be able to handle
the power of the stones just long enough
to perform the snap many fans have
wondered why was Tony Stark able to
control the power of the stones so
easily at the end before he performed
the snap it seemed like the Hulk had a
much harder time handling the gauntlet
controlling all of the Infinity stones
to snap and bring everybody back
whereas with Iron Man he
able to control the stones pretty well
it wasn't until after he snapped that
the power of the stones destroyed him
and there's a very specific purpose for
this Tony Stark specifically made his
last Iron Man suit to be able to harness
the power of the stones and this is the
reason that the Infinity Gauntlet that
Tony Stark built was made out of
nanotechnology out of Iron Man's armor
Tony specifically built this gauntlet to
where he could be able to use the stones
and the gauntlet with his specific suit
at the end of the movie and that's why
he was able to take the stones from
Thanos at the end because this gauntlet
was designed as a part of the Iron Man
armor and remembered Tony actually built
the suit a few years before the Avengers
went back in time I know a lot of people
think that Tony randomly discovered the
way to time travel after Scott Steven
etosha came to him but he had been
working on time travel for years ever
since the snap this isn't something that
Tony just thought about when Steve Scott
and Natasha showed up he had been
working on it the whole entire time Tony
knew that the stones were in the past
and Tony knew that somebody was going to
have to put on the Infinity Gauntlet and
snap and Tony always intended it to be
himself which is why he built that Iron
Man armor so if you needed a reason to
love Tony Stark even more his last suit
that he built wasn't for protecting him
it wasn't for him it was for the world
so be sure to let me know what you think
about the fact that Tony Stark built his
last Iron Man armor not to save himself
but to save the world let me know your
thoughts in the comments down below and
of course be sure to comment with your
favorite superhero or villain like this
video and subscribe to my channel if
you'd like to enter my giveaway and stay
up to date on everything relating to the
MCU as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof